alors comment ça m'a mis là autant
vouloir conçoit alors c'est qu'il reste
quatre jours et ouais et les chéris hier
c'était la fête des pères ouais et j'ai
ramené les cadeaux que l'on fait mes
enfants voulaient les montres aux
téléspectateurs et vous allez voir il ya
une barque a alors y'a mon fils bino
déjà houleux sané bon c'est la fête des
pères généralement vos enfants ils vont
réveil à 4h du matin ce qu'ils veulent
pas rater la fête des pères dimanche en
émoi ces genres cap heures du matin et
montrent surtout ni comment ça tu es
sont prêts
c'est la peine des pères est toi tu sors
mon père tu va me sortir de chroniques
noël mamère alors regardez mon fils il
m'a fait un très beau dessin
bonne fête des pères voilà et là est le
gars manière marchand de glaces hisser à
bord parce qu'il sait que je kiffe e
fruits et le truc c'est beau à regarder
voilà ça c'est mon fils section mois se
font alors et jolie emma fille elle a
fait un petit cahier voulez vous lire et
elle a dit en fait et vous la définit ce
que c'était un papa donc à la fin un
truc elle a fait comme ça donc qu'un
pape a le tempérament ça c'est moi elle
a mis un papa et qu'est-ce que sa femme
à barbe à papa
c'est très gentil un papa c'est très
gentil un papa c'est fort voilà
lcl c'est que je met des années à cannes
c'est qu'il met d'etagnac ateliers de
ses chéris c'est pas parce que je médite
ta nea castany que je suis très fort
c'est vrai que je fais d'abord parce que
j'ai toujours à mes enfants que personne
ne peut me battre à à whisky est pas fou
ici hein quoi dans l'émission c à fond
quand même ça j'avais battu il n'ya pas
de mal dans les salles ici ou ailleurs
elle fait mal dans l'émission amenez moi
des gens là mais moi tout ce que je
faisais un papa ça regarde la télé avec
un papa ça sort un papa ça conduit à
mais aussi dans le monde
il y a des papas qui fument et moi je
fume pas et elle a pas mis ça et elle a
pas la mire un papa aussi
ça regarde son téléphone et un papa ça
va chez nike
il embrasse fort alors franchement voilà
donc c'est et c'était franchement baudis
et ça c'est vrai elle a bien résumé
famille et annick genty y voilà emma
marois est tu vas voir
j'espère bien te vas voir tu sais quand
tu te maries généralement tu as toujours
une ou disons qu'ils font allait bientôt
espérons enfin espérons
on s'est compris quand est ce qui va
arriver le petit tu connais menasra
commencé vont avoir une semaine de maria
comptait jusque là aussi tu as quelqu'un
là qui arrive à un enfant ou quelque
chose quelqu'un qui viendra d'audience
[Rires]
tu vas nous le relations au top et qui
fait tout